grab the tissue box amman is opening up
about her and david bowie's epic romance
nearly five years after his death i
can't believe it's been fun
speaking with people magazine the model
says she has no plans to remarry which
was a question her daughter recently
brought up she recalls telling her
daughter quote no i will not i still
feel married someone a few years ago
referred to david as my late husband and
i said no he's not my late husband he's
my husband uh yeah iman also spoke about
how bowie's memory lives on telling
people
i definitely feel his presence
especially when i look out over the
glorious sunsets at her home because
david loves sunset so in that way he is
ever present through my memory
my love lives oh
i don't know that's so sweet and iman
recently appeared on the today show
where she revealed how the pandemic
helped her with her grieving process and
later brought hoda cotby to tears while
discussing her new fragrance fragrance
love memoir in honor of her late husband
take a look
i have a daughter who was a teenager
when my father passed away so i was
really more concentrated in helping her
go through her grief and i thought oh
yes i did go through my grief but i
actually did not and so last year i went
to my house upstate
and this beautiful property that that i
haven't spent time there since my
husband passed away and there i was
stuck for the year and divorced his time
he was there he had to deal with and all
of a sudden grief knocked on the door
and there became
a companion
and i went through all of it and now it
is the joy that i remember yeah you
actually wore his fragrance for all for
a while and then you wanted to create
something that was
more than that more about your love
story together yeah i mean it's a
tribute to to love what has happened
last year is really unique it's not just
the individual but it's the universe
yeah we all been through it uh so what i
really wanted to create was a fragrance
that had a bit of him which is the very
there and i've been wearing only his
fragrance for the past five years
and so but it creates something that was
a tribute to love
uh and an eternal love an eternal
devotion that and i think at the end of
the day at the end of our days the only
thing we will have
if we are lucky is our memories
don't cry
it's beautiful but yeah but that's that
that's the thing that we will have and
will sustain us after the the person
passes away
[Laughter]
oh thank you
thanks i'm sorry i don't even know
what's happening i'm really sorry